[Music]
people have been steaming food for
thousands of years
once upon a time steamers were made out
of clay pots with perforated floors
today we've come up with all sorts of
metal and plastic innovations the
traditional bamboo steamer is a perfect
balance between the old and the new
perfected by generations of craftsmen
traditional bamboo steamers are
lightweight strong and durable they look
like simple cooking tools but building
them requires enormous artisanal skill
the craftsman buys lengths of bamboo
from local farmers he uses a traditional
planer he crafted himself to smooth the
bamboo joints a customized chopper tool
helps him split the bamboo lengthwise he
inserts a bamboo stick to hold the split
open after removing the chopper he pulls
on the stick to split the entire length
of the bamboo the craftsman splits the
sections again to assemble the steamer
base the craftsman will split the bamboo
into 32 pieces the cover will require
128 pieces a custom-made knife knocks
down the inner sections of the bamboo
for the steamers cover the craftsman
splits the bamboo horizontally next the
craftsman uses this slicing tool to cut
the wood
he sets the desired width and slices a
thin sheet of wood lengthwise he uses
this section of wood to form the base of
the steamer and slides a bamboo ring
over it to hold it in place then he
punches small holes with the drill and
reinforces the joint with stainless
steel wire the installation process
begins first by installing a series of
inner rings which will serve to
reinforce the structure of the steamer
and to support multiple levels of
steamers inside it the craftsman uses
special techniques to ensure that each
joint is perfectly aligned for maximum
strength working almost entirely by hand
with skills acquired over time he
meticulously creates a strong yet
lightweight piece of kitchen equipment
[Music]
the basket still needs a bottom to rest
dumplings in the craftsmen begins
building the basket floor by custom
fitting a series of rugged cross pieces
he ensures that each piece fits
perfectly before proceeding then he
inserts thin more pliable pieces of
bamboo to hold the cross pieces in place
next he lays the final layer on top
placing the pieces with their outer
sides facing up to form a smooth surface
for food to sit on while steaming
with the floor of the steamer in place
it's time to secure the upper pieces by
binding them to the support pieces to do
this he threads a stainless steel wire
through the cracks twisting the ends
tightly to the base then he gives the
inner support rings under the steamer
floor a few taps securing them in place
the baskets base is now complete
[Music]
next the craftsman begins weaving the
bamboo pieces together that will form
the cover he uses a traditional pattern
called a twill weave then he inserts
paper before adding a second layer of
bamboo the paper will help prevent steam
from escaping the basket too quickly he
then snaps in a series of carefully
sized reinforcements to keep the layers
in place
[Music]
finally he custom fits another interior
ring under the reinforcements to hold
everything together tapping it carefully
into position the steamer cover is now
complete